the Joe Rogan experience it's the
pattern because this is this is one of
the primary misconceptions that people
have about consuming meat when they hear
studies that say that meat is associated
with mortality or high cholesterol or
heart disease or all these different
factors we are talking about these kinds
of studies where people fill out a form
tell us what you eat yeah how many days
a week do you eat meat how many days a
week do you eat this what they don't
take into account is whether or not
these people are going to Wendy's
whether or not they're eating a
grass-fed steak and and and you know and
broccoli something healthy there's a
giant difference between those two
things but they're lumped in together
because this is meat consumption yeah
there's that the studies aren't perfect
for sure but you were saying that
basically looking saying we should look
at outcomes and not just look at
individual markers right is that
basically no I'm saying we should look
at the diet quality the overall diet
pattern so if my example christopher
gardner did a study at stanford a couple
years ago and he took - instead of
saying you know low fat low carb he took
two groups and he advised them all to
basically eat a healthy diet and then
one group ate a low-fat healthy diet and
the other group ate a low-carb healthy
diet they all lost weight it wasn't that
big of a difference between the two I
agree I agree so first of all in terms
of health I would be pretty my opinion
would be I'm pretty much micronutrient
agnostic so I wouldn't like I'm not
advocating high carb or low carb I think
that people can do healthy and well I
think for athletes they need a lot more
carbs and sauce getting those from
plants I think there's certain athletes
that can if it's slow in steady state
where you're getting more fat oxidation
I think that you know stone steady state
athletes can do but like an MMA fight or
a soccer play but you just said that you
were you were not low-carb right you
said you're not low cop I'm not I'm not
a low carb I advocate I've written
articles called seven things seven
reasons you should be cautious I'm not
saying I'm not local Oh carb advocate I
don't believe everyone should be on a
low-carb diet
but the thing is Chris has it doesn't
have the consensus definitions of
carbohydrate levels you've made up your
own definitions right when did I make up
my own slide 80 Jamie if you do that
please I just point out that Zach bitter
the man who I had on the podcast
yesterday who holds the world record in
running a hundred miles in 11 hours and
I think it's 18 minutes
he's on a low carbohydrate diet yeah and
again you know those slow and steady
state you can do well so you so Chris
your recommendation your your definition
of low carb is 10 to 15 percent if you
know the next slide really want so if
you look at the peer-reviewed literature
it's either less than 30 percent or the
next slide generally less than 40
percent like if you look across all the
literature's less than 30 or 40 moderate
carb according to Chris next slide Jamie
would be 15 to 30 peer-reviewed
literature next car and next slide 40 to
65 and then high carb Chris calls more
than 30 percent in the peer-reviewed
literature high carb more than 65 and
the next slide more than 70 depending on
the peer-reviewed literature so you've
come up with your own definitions of
what is low moderate and high carb
yeah just for the purpose you just said
my work with people that that's not
relate I wasn't trying to represent
research there Joe that's what I
consider to be low carb moderate carb
and high carb in my work with patients
my recommendation did you know him says
he did I mean that is what you said
I mean you when you wrote this out you
did have a different definition than the
purity that you do right out of that by
his definition have your own idea and he
said not a car you heard him say no yes
and so slide slide idea so I just want
to sum this up but what's the point here
I said that everyone should be on a
low-carb diet no I agree
and I've always argued that it depends
on everything from your genes to your
exercise pattern
are you getting your numbers from like
when you write low carb moderate carbon
high carb you make them up this is just
a wreck this this is a clinical
recommendation from my experience
working with patients I'm not
representing the scientific literature
here I'm not trying to make arguments
about madness that that's absolute
madness to come up with your own
definitions and this is why I feel that
Chris does get it and when you have
people like Chris on at multiple times
it throws people's perception officer
what is a healthy diet because Chris
misrepresents the data he comes up his
own definitions of things he
misrepresents things that we said in the
film okay let's just talk about this
real quick what so when we're talking
about low carb moderate carb or high
carb when you're recommending to your
patients low carb moderate carb or high
carb these definitions how are you
coming to these conclusions it's made
them up no based on so there are a lot
of people James that disagree with the
the cart the range is scientific in in
yeah there's a scientific consensus how
many different scientists were were
polled on this how many different
studies were shown but almost this is
something that you just found that
disputes his position it's like a large
group of no this is okay so slide 89
consider Verta health who uses you know
vert the folks at Verta
who are all scientists and these they
use a ketogenic very low carb diet - you
will not be in ketosis at 30%
carbohydrate or 25 percent or 20 percent
or even 15 percent you for you know that
and and then you know 40 to 65 percent
you're not you're not-- you're not even
in the ballpark
you know so if we're thinking about
using low carbohydrate diets for example
for weight loss or for diabetes or you
know metabolic issues like
health is doing then you low-carb is not
going to be 30 to 40% okay that's not
gonna work so that's where my
recommendation is based on OSIS based on
know based on the optimal range if you
have if you look at the rest of the
article it's going to be like if you've
got diabetes you've got you're
overweight you're obese you're trying to
lose weight this is the range that I've
found and other experts like the people
at Verta health have found will be most
effective and these are its branches
there's no representation that this is
the range that is defined as low carb in
the scientific literature
so you're do you're tall you calling it
low carb because if someone's on a
ketogenic low-carb diet in order to get
into ketosis you have to have a low
number of carbohydrates actually
probably even below 10 it's not even
just to be in ketosis like just to get
the the maximal weight loss you know
someone could be at 15% and still guess
all right weight loss without being in
Quito I got her in dropped because you
just like in the last five minutes you
showed a study from trying to prove your
own point but low carb and low fat
people had equiv equivalent fat loss you
just said that so why not you now all of
a sudden advocating only low carb diets
for that they can both work it for
different people but James you're
misrepresenting what he was saying what
he was saying is getting people to go on
a healthy diet versus the standard
American diet yeah so he's not just
talking about low carb versus high carb
what he's talking about is getting off
[ __ ] like processed foods and sugar
and eating I totally agree and when you
do that people no matter what low carb
or high carb lose weight but I think you
will agree as well as almost anybody
would that getting on a low carbohydrate
diet and forcing your body into ketosis
makes your body burn fat that's one way
that's true but it's it's proven right
no the other piece of this is most of
the studies aren't comparing a healthy
omnivorous diet with a you know
plant-based vegan diet they're comparing
a vegan diet with a standard American
diet that contains animal products like
pay higher salaries neutral or diet yes
by the way yeah has any of your work or
your ideas been published in the
scientific literature I've never claimed
that I just wondered
so you didn't wonder no I did one no I
couldn't find that way we're saying that
you were saying that to try to make it
seem that he's less of an expert yes
I'm not an expert either so what what's
the point why here because why am I here
well I actually I did ask if I could
bring my chief science advisor who has a
double master's degree in exercise
physiology and nutrition he's a
registered dietician he built would've
read all of his papers and we can talk
about him totally
[Applause]